gather round they're celebrating but I  lamech revolutionaries for dated power  yesterday running time back since is  coming apart at the seams  brother Danny here by order of the  Revolutionary Guards  Sharia law now ruled the land more look  happy it's been arrests I record show  that you travel to Israel  I'm a businessman who happens to be a  Jew we know everything about you tell me  where my husband is my son is doing the  cards what does that has become a  revolutionary man prophet is from the  corrupt regime he never cared  the only thing worse than a criminal is  a hypocrite God answered prayers think  that beard makes you a man of God you're  a stranger in my home leave now before  even know how to fight for what is yours  they've seen us  get down let's go please  please rated pg-13